brutal blunt-force trama infused with
blast damage let's go back into
dauntless and go through how to get the
best out of that hammer hello and
welcome to Playstation grenade are you
enjoying your time in dauntless by now
you probably have a favorite weapon but
may be thinking about mixing it up or
getting the most out of your armory well
without a doubt I think you should give
the hammer a go and you'll quickly see
why I love it so much we'll go through
the basics the fundamentals before
moving to more advanced attacks and the
ultimate aether smash combo which is
absolutely devastating so if you're
ready let's do this the first thing we
must understand is the role of the
hammer whoever wields it is there to
target the behemoths armor and most
importantly evolve the beasts head if
you're stuck at the tail end you aren't
as effective as you should be so when
it's hammer time
aim for the head so we have two
fundamental basic attacks to understand
the first is simply pressing square
three times without moving the second
attack is the same but also pushing in a
direction with your left thumbstick
do you notice the difference between the
two this comes down to the weapons games
as a basis look how wide the standing
attack is are now compare that to the
moving attack this directly links to
accuracy and placement the horizontal
versus the vertical the wide attack has
a higher chance of hitting the bahama
but the vertical attack has a narrow
gate designed to hit the behemoth at
bang on the head and this linked back to
our primary function as a hammer broke
hitting the beasts on the head as often
as we can there's also a variant of that
vertical attack we can change the motion
to an uppercut to do this we start
standing still and press square but then
we add movement so push towards your
target and hit square twice more double
uppercuts
so puts our theory hat back on why is
this important well remember we want
head shots an uppercut can hit a
behemoth whose head is quite high off
the ground
so as a basic rule of thumb smash the
hammer down on the behemoths heads that
are
and switch to uppercuts when they are at
head height no no pun intended there so
that's half the weapon done and dusted
but before we move on to the Beast
combos and attack patterns let's quickly
go over the other side the blast cannon
hidden inside that hammer so just like
any real-life hammer there's a shotgun
our cannon hidden inside to use it
simply press triangle it does have a
wide spread but arguably it's pretty
lackluster compared to the power of a
swinging hammer by holding down triangle
we can charge a shot which consumes
those files in the top left corner
resulting in this to reload
simply tap r1 did you notice the
animation when reloading in the top
corner this represents the perfect time
to reload by tapping our one again at
the centre point we will be awarded with
the quickest reload possible if we miss
this point the animation turns red to
show us our bullets are not running at
prime effectiveness and the animation
takes a little longer in fight the
shotgun element is an acceptable way to
cancel out of a combo to keep in the
same position but in every single other
scenario dodge role is the correct thing
to do to cancel out to the tax charging
up the cannon and releasing it at the
right time we'll see behemoth animations
interrupted resulting in that beast
going to ground allowing you to get up
close and personal and smash it on its
head once again oh and another great use
of a full barrage is on those minions
various behemoths have in fights boom
not missing the blasters have evasive
uses - whilst running we can tap
triangle to bunnyhop with a blast file
and by pressing triangle twice again
while running we can perform an
aggressive double jump we can use it to
evade or better still add a square
inputs and smash down upon the behemoth
I find it's a really good way to get to
the correct side so if you find yourself
at its butt
use this to get back to its head and I
know I keep saying this but we all know
why we hammer guys are all about the
headshots
[Music]
now things get impressive we can infuse
the hammer swings with aether blasts but
just before we do that let's showcase
the best combo at our disposal well
there's three in fact the ultimate combo
which if you try and unleash as often as
you can
comes in three variants they all start
with the same three square combo like we
showed earlier on but now add a triangle
hit to the end and boom
bloody spectacular the final blow will
use all four blast files or however many
you have at that point but check this
landing that final blow Awards ballistic
relief we get supercharged blast ammo in
return so hypothetically we can chain
the combo until our stamina meter
depletes other behemoths gets a hitting
it's now possible to take this further
but the following does require a little
timing
we can now infuse those blasts into our
hammer swings have a look-see during
each swing of our hammer we can
incorporate a blast attack by simply
pressing triangle before the shot lands
will shine yellow when it's done
correctly it's possible at any step of
the combo as long as you're swinging
your axe at the point you press triangle
so potentially during every single hit
and if we keep the killer combo in mind
we can in theory get back all the shots
without reloading if we hit our final
aether smash chaining the combo for
devastating effects honestly it's like a
wrecking ball and it feels great when
you nail it
but here's something you must keep in
mind bottoming will result in missing
either an instant reload or a blast
infusion and in the worst case scenarios
your character will start to go through
a manual reload and risk being hit by
the behemoth it all comes down to timing
on that combo you choose performing an
instant reload after every hit takes
time to get used to and honestly I still
mess it up all the other types
anyway it's possible to keep reloading
all four files until the final hit for
the most damage possible by a hammer
from now on we call this move stop
I'm at I'm sorry oh sorry anyway here's
the thumb work forward square triangle
r1 square triangle r1 square triangle
one triangle it's all timing based and
I'm terrible at timing so if I can do
this
you can do this anyway man had some
impressive combo okay so that's my guide
to using the hammer of course we didn't
look at the builds on modifiers this
episode was all about the basics in
battle and advanced attack patterns
please let me know your thoughts I would
love some feedback shall I keep going
with this series and what weapons shall
we break down next as a last call to
action if you buy anything in the game
please think about using my Creator code
a damaru AD am aru as i receive a few
pennies from everything you buy in-game
I'll use that money to make more content
like this I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]